this episode of things you missed is
brought to you by the C's world merch
store stick around to the end of this
video to hear about our free merch give
away the biggest theme that I picked up
on in the shape of water was actually
not water but rather time right off from
the opening scene we are bombarded with
symbols related to time eliza's life is
constantly on a tight schedule she keeps
an alarm clock and a watch on the table
next to her bed just two of many clocks
seen around her apartment she's always
on top of keeping track of the date
using her calendar the calendar also
features quotes on the back of each page
one of which compares the flow of a
river to the flow of time but despite
all of this she is constantly late
whenever she shows up to work her
co-worker Zelda always has to rush her
and pull her to the front of the time
stamp line so she can clock in on time
the time stamps by the way are another
time reference because being on time
seems to be a huge deal at the company
that they work at there's a huge clock
in the outside of the building and
director Guillermo del Toro really wants
his audience to notice the time motif
but the question is what does it mean
one of the timers that Eliza has in her
apartment is a kitchen timer which is
shaped like an egg eggs may have a
greater significance than just being the
food that Eliza feeds amphibian man they
don't really give him a name in this
movie so I guess I'll just call him Gabe
gate bian but if you look at it in a
broader more symbolic sense in terms of
their relationship
Eliza offers her eggs to Gabe which
could be seen as a symbol of
reproductive fertility especially given
the weird stuff that comes down later
which takes us back to Eliza's egg timer
because human fertility is on a rather
strict timer as well which eliza who
looks to be in her 40s is coming up on
and like Dimitri's Tyler the one he
attaches to the building circuit panel
once time is up it's lights out although
that could just be a reference to death
we do see the first kill take place in
that scene as a result there is also a
scene where Eliza is waiting for the bus
and sits next to a man holding a
birthday cake a symbol for aging then
Giles during the part where he's feeling
rejected and unwanted says he feels he
was born too early or too late which is
most likely a response to him being
kicked out of his favorite pie place
because of his sexual orientation he
wishes he lived in an era where he could
be accepted for who he is that also
plays a part in the reason he helps
Eliza because he can relate to her in
the sense that most of the world doesn't
understand him that's not to say Giles
didn't need something Vincent and a slap
in the face to get him going though did
anyone notice Eliza checking her watch
right before hitting him this could be
her trying to break out of her shell she
is usually quiet reserved and as I
mentioned always late but in order to
save Gabe she knows she has to change to
challenge authority and be spot on time
in order for the heist to work we know
this because they have to synchronize
their watches and there's a four minute
window to success Eliza still does end
up being late during the heist but she
gets lucky when Demetri ends up being on
their side when Eliza develops her next
plan to release Gabe on October 10th
she's once again faced with the time
challenge Demetri tells her she needs to
release him by then as a health concern
trickling is given until then to bring
back the asset with his life on the line
so he bears after the fish snapper
leaving Eliza no time to spare anyway it
is only then that she finally makes it
to the docks on time and gets herself
and Gabe to safety presumably also
beating the biological clock as she
takes a dive with Gabe this movies so
weird the use of colour also seems to
tie into the time theme that del Toro
has woven into the story this is
explained when Giles presents his
artwork to the jello company and they
tell him that they don't want red jello
anymore because green is the color of
the future which led me to assume that
red represented the past we also see
some yellows in this movie so maybe they
represent the press
you can let me know your own ideas in
the comments I think one of the reasons
I can get behind the idea is because we
see Strickland's transition to becoming
what the Cadillac dealer refers to as a
man of the future when we first see
Strickland's family they're all wearing
yellow and everything in the house is
yellow but he really wants to get ahead
of the curve in order to impress the
company that he works for we're
literally everything is green or teal
they're interchangeable here he buys the
teal car and as he's driving home he
passes a group of people in another
Cadillac they are all wearing yellow
this is the visual metaphor of him
pulling out of the past into the future
we know he's always craving green since
we see him carry around those green
candies he enjoys so much
we know he's unsatisfied with his yellow
wife and he goes after Eliza a green who
is much more innovative and
forward-thinking after he gets the car
we start to see his family transition to
green at least in their wardrobe but his
wife stays the same
he Liza on the other hand may be painted
it's one of the most future-oriented
characters because she's always seen in
green and was a large emerald throughout
the movie the only time we see her
regressed to red is when she loses
confidence and she's seen crying in the
locker room I also noticed that in
Strickland's office there are three
phones red black and green I'd have to
see the movie again to remember who
called on which phone but I'm willing to
bet it plays into the color trends that
I've been pointing to Giles is also
another example I can use he's going
after the job to draw that jello
advertisement as I mentioned and while
doing so he has cravings for key lime
pie which is deal after getting rejected
he's feeling down and reverts to
ordering a red pie it looked like maybe
cherry but when it comes to the heist he
knows he has to step up his game and as
he mentioned be brave like Liza so he
wears green for that I could probably go
on and on because every shot in the
movie is coated with these colors so let
me know what you noticed in the Commons
it's mentioned that green and teal are
perceived very similarly I would maybe
call some of those shades like the soap
in the bathroom for example more of an
aquamarine because believe me I know
that
I know that color I know that color
I think aquamarine is an appropriate
color choice for such an aqua heavy
movie outside of the obvious flood
bursting at the bathroom door Steph
there was some interesting and poetic
uses of water in the movie such as
Strickland intentionally spilling his
glass of water to get Eliza to come
clean it up in doing so he takes
advantage of Eliza his love for the
aquatic to try to seduce her and as we
know it doesn't work and Strickland has
made an example of buy another one of
Eliza's calendar quotes life is but the
shipwreck of our plans he is much like
the Greek mythological figure Tantalus
who Giles references earlier in the
movie he was made to stand in a pool of
water beneath the fruit tree with low
branches with the fruit ever alluding
his grasp in the water always receding
before he could take a drink when Dmitri
first meets the Russian spies at that
one restaurant they order surf and turf
this continues the trend of characters
ordering the very thing that they're
going after the Russians want control
over an amphibious creature meaning he
can get round underwater or on land surf
or turf the water mate also foreshadowed
the connection shared by Eliza and Gabe
we see early on that she loves the idea
of being underwater this could have
something to do with the fact that she's
mute and you can only communicate and
sign under the surface but she dreams of
living underwater before she ever meets
Gabe and early on she's seen
masturbating in the tub which is the
same place that she ends up hiding Gabe
so that could allude to their sexual
relationship and then the bathroom is
the first place that they well you get
the picture and finally we have the last
quote of the film delivered by Giles
unable to perceive the shape of you I
find you all around me he's talking
about water which as I mentioned in my
last video has no set molecular
structure no shape but once emerged the
subject is completely surrounded by it
the story of the silent princess comes
full circle beginning and ending with
her fully submerged in water in both the
opening and ending scenes we see the
next major motif shoes one of the wisest
shoes can be seen floating in the closet
in the opening dream sequence and when
she joins Gabe in the ocean at the end
of the journey the shoe is seen slipping
off of her
it's almost as if she's been dreaming
about a fish person coming into her life
and sweeping her off her feet all along
but that's really weird to think about
in the last video we talked about the
idea of shoes representing her life on
land and her not needing them in the
ocean so the shoe slipping off her foot
could represent her giving up her life
on the land I'm going to take that
theory one step further
pun intended and say that Eliza's shoes
represent her way of artistic expression
and communication and while living
underwater no longer needs them early on
we see her cleaning the shoes to give
them that crisp tap sound so when she's
prancing down the hall or tap-dancing
with Giles in front of the TV she
expresses herself rhythmically or
musically she's obviously interested in
music and singing as evidenced by her
whistling and the part where she
actually speaks and imagines herself
singing on stage with Gabe we also see
her literally using that tapping sound
to communicate like when she taps the
wall to get Giles attention or when
Zelda asked her to tap the phone so she
knows that Eliza is listening whoa hold
up a second timeout how weird is it that
I've been using this Legend of Zelda
clip to demonstrate the extended
lifespan of an fibia fish people and
then it turns out there's a character in
this movie named Zelda and then on top
of that there's a character who's
referred to as a princess and then on
top of that we have a silent protagonist
who wears green I just thought I'd point
that out if you know what I'm talking
about leave a like on this video but
anyways back on topic here Zelda
complains that her feet are killing her
and while they're working so if the
shoes are the thing that grounds you to
the land on the surface and Eliza is
ditching them to be with her soul mate
underwater then Zelda shoes must
represent her marriage to her husband
which we later find out is not a good
situation maybe I'm looking too far into
that I don't know I'm sure I'll hear
from you guys if I am much of the movie
has Gabe locked up with Eliza and Zelda
trying to get him to freedom both
characters have symbols of flying free
on them
Zelda has this bird pin that she wears
during the breakout scene and there are
also some similar birds on the wall in
her home Eliza has a butterfly jewel on
her collar
they had this wardrobe display set up at
my theatre so here's a better look take
this with a grain of salt but Strickland
tells Eliza he thinks he can make her
squawk which is possibly another bird
reference
in any event we can infer that
Strickland has no game whatsoever Gabe
on the other hand you know what this
will probably never seem normal to me no
matter how many times I see this movie
one other thing that stood out to me was
what appeared to be an Egyptian
hieroglyphics design on Giles couch
the ancient Egyptians are known for
building the Sphinx and actually
worshiping cats as gods
you'll notice that Giles has over a
million cats running around he has so
many of that it's not even a big deal
when Gabe bites one of their heads off
the cat by the way was named Pandora
which is another reference to Greek
mythology according to Strickland the
Cape had been worshipped by the
Amazonians as a God as well before he
was captured in a river in South America
and for those of you who are going to
ask yes I do still think it's possible
that Gabe is unofficially The Creature
from the Black Lagoon the information we
got in the movie only furthers the
notion and when Gabe carries Eliza into
the water just before the credits rolled
I immediately got a flashback to the way
the creature it picks up K and carries
her in Creature from the Black Lagoon it
almost had to be a nod from del Toro but
my point is that the Amazonians
worshiped Gabe as divinity and by the
end of the movie he makes a case that he
really isn't God by healing some
injuries John Coffey style giving the
lives of the power to control water and
possibly causing it to rain so that the
canal would fill up in time for the
floodgates to open
he is also captivated at the movie
theater watching the story of Ruth which
I haven't seen
but apparently involves the worship of
gods and idols did anyone else catch
that the movie theater was supposedly
scientifically air-conditioned um what
does that even mean
anyway let's see what else we've got in
here there are a couple of posters in
the women's locker room to analyze the
first is a simple PSA by the city of
Baltimore to save water the other says
loose lips might sink ships my first
thought was the song EXO by Fall Out Boy
but given that the movie takes place 43
years before from Under the Cork Tree
came out I decided to look it up and
apparently it was an actual piece of
World War 2 propaganda basically
encouraging soldiers not to give away
their plans
the enemy I find the choice kind of
ironic considering that Eliza has no
voice due to her neck being injured as a
baby it's not entirely clear what
happens at the end of the movie but I
got the sense that her neck scars ended
up being a blessing in disguise because
Gabe turns them into gills
it seemed like she was able to breathe
underwater at the end but let me know
how you perceived it too it was also
symbolic how Gabe stabbed Strickland in
the throat at the end so that as the
lies and moves to a place where she
doesn't need her voice Strickland is
silenced and if there's a meaning behind
Strickland's death I think his initial
injury where he loses his fingers is
also significant he ends up losing his
ring finger and his pinky finger the
pinky represents a promise he made to
his superior general Hoyt to protect the
asset which he breaks the ring finger
represents his marriage to his wife with
whom he is unfaithful he tries to
reattach these fingers to patch the
mistakes that he has made but because
his character is not genuine
they never mesh back into his body and
he just ends up ripping them out again I
just opened up the new ceases world of
merch store and there are some killer
designs that you're gonna want to get
your claws on like Suzie's world and
kill the Seas world's cafe and the
classic logo design I'm also gonna give
away a free merch item to one lucky
contest winner all you have to do to
enter is upload a picture of yourself
with one item from the merch store and
tag Suzie's world you can enter as many
photos as you want with the same merch
item full contest rules can be found in
the description and with that I will let
you grab your camera and get to work
but first make sure you like this video
and subscribe to Suzie's worlds for new
Horrors every week ring that DEATH
BATTLE for notifications and i'll see
you in the next one assuming we both
survive